[Musique]
il
bonsoir à tous nous sommes ensemble
comme chaque jour du lundi au jeudi
jusqu'à 21h30 pour décrypter les grands
titres de l'actualité de la journée au
sommaire de ce jeudi 25 novembre le
gouvernement intensifie la pression sur
les non vaccinés pour contrer la
cinquième vague de kobe 19 l'ouverture
de la dose de rappel à partir de samedi
pour tous les adultes elle sera
obligatoire pour un pass and it est
invalide le port du masque redevient lui
obligatoire partout en intérieur en
échappe en revanche au couvre-feu et or
confinement à ce stade alors et ton
rentrer dans une spirale infernale
notamment sur la vaccination
on en débat dans quelques instants et on
attend évidemment vos réactions comme
chaque soir sur le conte télégramme
verte et france
la crise migratoire à nouveau au coeur
des inquiétudes en europe au lendemain
du naufrage meurtrier de 27 migrants
dans la manche paris appelle à améliorer
la coopération sur le vieux continent
une réunion aura lieu dimanche à calais
avec plusieurs ministres de lieux en
charge de l'immigration et la commission
européenne
l'union européenne qui doit aussi
répondre à une autre crise migratoire
celle à la frontière de la pologne et de
la biélorussie alors comment gérer ces
flux de migrants à quelle formule pour
sortir d'un éternel bras de fer entre
les pays quel enjeu surtout derrière
tout ça avec le risque d'un
affaiblissement de l'europe on tentera
de mieux comprendre les choses ce soir
avec le géopolitologue alexandre del
vals
et puis on s'intéressera ensuite au
mouvement de contestation qui secoue la
guadeloupe et la martinique véhicules
calcinés incendies pillages et barrages
routiers les deux ils sont paralysés
depuis dix jours par une crise sociale
et économique elle a fait surface après
une opposition à l'obligation vaccinale
des soignants alors cette crise est elle
prévisible qu'elles sont liées cause
confondez jusqu'où peut-on aller le
dossier sera sur la table dès 21h et
parmi les raison justement des colères
aux antilles l'inégalité sociale
renforcée par la crise sanitaire ou
encore la baisse du pouvoir d'achat la
pauvreté s'est elle a gravé en france
métropolitaine tout comme en outre-mer
depuis le coc vite sur la question deux
thèses s'affrontent si l'on croit
l'insee la politique du quoi qu'il en
coûte liés à la pandémie a permis de
stabiliser cette pauvreté alors que dans
son dernier rapport le secours
catholique tire la sonnette d'alarmé
alors qui croire éléments de réponse
tout à l'heure avec l'économiste jacques
sapir
la france n'y échappe donc pas plusieurs
mesures sont prises pour lutter contre
la cinquième bague de kovy 19 troisième
dose de vaccin port du masque parce
sanitaires le ministre de la santé
olivier ferrand a listé les restrictions
aujourd'hui on retrouve notre reporter
nadège à des rasades devant le ministère
de la santé bonsoir nadège l'annoncent
phare du gouvernement donc le rappel
vaccinal ouvert désormais à tous les
majeurs
absolument stéphanie le rythme
s'accélère cette cinquième vague de
contaminations inquiète les autorités il
ya deux semaines emmanuel macron annoncé
cette dose de rappel aux seuls français
âgés de plus de 65 ans voici
qu'aujourd'hui à son ministre de la
santé la réclame pour tous l es français
âgés de plus de 18 ans qui voudront
conserver leurs passes et sanitaires au
15 janvier prochain je vous propose
d'écouter olivier ferrand à ce sujet
désormais le rappel vaccinal sera ouvert
à tous les adultes âgés de 18 ans et
plus des cinq mois après leur dernière
injection ce qui veut dire qu en
pratique cela concerne 25 millions de
français 25 millions de français dont 6
millions ont déjà reçu leur appel il
reste donc 10 9 millions de français à
date qui deviennent éligibles pour le
rappel de vaccination et que nous
invitons donc à se faire vacciner dans
les deux prochains mois
ce rappel vaccinal 1 n'est pas la seule
annonce faite par olivier véran
aujourd'hui le masque va redevenir
obligatoire en intérieur dans les lieux
accueillant du public et également ceux
soumis aux passes sanitaire est la durée
de validité des tests pcr et antigénique
va être réduite à 24 heures contre 72
actuellement et nadège des mesures qui
font beaucoup réagir dans l'opposition
[Musique]
absolument et slaves à gauche comme à
droite alors quand certains parlent
d'une pression vaccinale d'un contrôle
social d'autres déplorent le fait que
les tests de dépistage soit toujours
payant pour les personnes non vaccinées
et cela en pleine reprise épidémique
le gouvernement s'obstine pas de test
gratuit pour tous pas de détecteur de
co2 pas de télétravail étendue pas de
mobilisation massive sur les gestes
barrières avec cette stratégie là on
aura de très mauvaises surprises dès les
prochaines semaines au lieu de rendre
les tests gratuits et de déployer des
purificateurs d'air seule mesure
efficace contre la circulation virale le
tandem macron vers ont choisi à nouveau
la pression vaccinale et le contrôle
social quand vous avez quelqu'un qui
n'est pas vacciné qui ne se teste pas
parce que le test coûte 25 euros et qui
donc est potentiellement contagieux pour
tout son entourage est bien le problème
c'est que potentiellement c'est une
bombe humaine donc il faut effectivement
qu'il puisse vite s'isoler et faire en
sorte d'être traité comme il se doit
obliger via le pass sanitaire un rappel
tous les cinq mois et non plus six comme
l'envisagent le gouvernement permet de
faire 2,4 12 par an contre 2 soit 20% de
chiffre d'affaires en plus bien joué 16
heures
le vaccin on fire qui vient d'ailleurs
tout juste d'être autorisé pour les
enfants âgés de 5 à 11 ans par le
régulateur européen du médicament
annonce qui a ouvre donc la voie à une
vaccination de cette tranche d'âge en
l'union européenne à la relis vielles
verront à s'est exprimé au sujet sur le
sujet aujourd'hui il a déclaré que rien
ne sera fait avant 2022 mais 2022 c'est
dans moins de cinq semaines maintenant
donc la vaccination pour les enfants
pourrait donc arriver très très vite en
france qui vend 2022 c'est demain merci
nadège adhéra that en direct donc du
ministère de la santé oms vient de
l'entente donc le gouvernement qui
ouvrira le rappel vaccinal à l'ensemble
des adultes dès ce samedi sous peine de
voir leurs passes sanitaire invalides à
partir du 15 janvier pour les 15-64 ans
alors le gouvernent va-t-il trop loin en
ciblant des 18 ans qu'on est il de tous
ceux qui refusent de se faire vacciner
et on rentrait dans une spirale
infernale on attend toujours vos
réactions sur le conte télégramme
berthet france et place maintenant au
décryptage
[Musique]
et pour en parler sur ce plateau jacques
eric revel éditorialiste politique
bonsoir eric revel merci d'être avec
nous maxime thibeault avocat au barreau
de paris merci d'être avec nous
également en duplex pour nous
accompagner arnaud chiche anesthésistes
fondateur du collectif santé en danger
et puis arno fabre également nous
rejoindra plus tard enseignants
administrateur national des stylos
rouges pour voir le volet scolaire parce
que là aussi il ya quelques petites
mesures annoncées par le gouvernement on
met clairement maxime thibeault la
pression sur les non vaccinés c'est pas
nouveau mais enfin ça s'accélère une
obligation vaccinale qui dit pas son nom
est tendue à quasiment tout le monde
sort on s'y attendait pas nécessairement
sauf les enfants s'est interrogé le
juriste que vous êtes bien sûr alors en
fait la réponse est dans votre question
c'est à dire que tout est dans le
cynisme est rien et explicite là on
s'attendrait d'un gouvernement dans un
état civilisé qui fasse preuve de
pédagogie que toutes choses soient
clairement voté que la loi soit comprise
par l'ensemble et si on a des manoeuvres
on a créé le pass sanitaires on a
sollicité du conseil d'éteindre ses avis
pour savoir s'il était légal et
constitutionnel ce dernier n'a même pas
prononcer le fait que le pass sanitaire
c'était une obligation vaccinale de fait
le conseil constitutionnel après avait
fait fed a défait de même et aujourd'hui
on se rend compte d'une chose c'est que
le pass sanitaire va permettre d'imposer
le rappel vaccinal qui aura lieu tous
les six mois et on est en train de
s'installer en fait dans un système qui
me dérange beaucoup ou le principe n'est
plus la liberté le principe devient
d'interdiction et pour retrouver la
liberté eh bien il faut avoir un pass
sanitaire faut avoir un passeport et ça
ça proprement scandaleux parce que
l'état d'urgence qui devait être
exceptionnelle qui devait être limité
dans le temps devient quelque chose qui
s'installe dans le droit commun devienne
quelque chose avec lequel on va devoir
vivre et on ne sort progressivement
d'une logique d'état de droit et donc
bien sûr que pour quelqu'un tu y es
amoureux des libertés et en tant que que
tu as défendeurs chaque jour de ses
libertés à titre individuel ou collectif
je suis choqué par ce qui se passe on va
voir avant de vous donner la parole eric
revel une première réaction celle de
marie sur télégramme qui me parvient à
l'instant les personnes qui ont accepté
ces injections doivent aller à la
troisième dose sachant que la quatrième
est déjà annoncée en israël c'est vrai
que c'est un petit peu le laboratoire de
la planète en l'état hébreu on ne
s'arrête jamais point d'interrogation se
demande marie c'est vrai qu'une dose de
rappel pour les adultes 5 mois après la
dernière injection et + 6 mois ça a été
raccourci à ce rythme on va faire
beaucoup de piqûres eric revel ouais
ouais j'ai bien noté parce que ça me
concerne c'est rapidement maintenant la
salle close
non je plaisante un peu mais en fait je
vous dire je pas si vous vous souvenez
en mai 68 alors qu'on parle bien de par
exemple pierre viansson-ponté qui est
éditorialiste du monde avait écrit la
france s'ennuie voyez bien aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que la france est
fatiguée parce que elles courent
derrière quelque chose que le
gouvernement n'arrive pas à rattraper
c'est pour moi l'adaptation
l'improvisation permanente
tu veux dire je suis absolument pas
médecin absolument pas spécialiste mais
je me dis que tient en période hivernale
ça me semble assez normal que que des
maladies respiratoires reprennent un peu
le dessus bah tiens c'est justement ce
qui est en train de se passer est ce
qu'on n'aurait pas pu prévoir tout ça un
peu plus expliqué comment il avait des
buttes leur être plus dans la pédagogie
qui attendait quand vous avez un peu de
mémoire quand même je parle que pour le
pays que je connais mieux celui ci mais
on nous raconte tout et n'importe quoi
en permanence souvenez vous
lorsqu'on nous allions atteindre 60%
d'immunité populationnelle il y aurait
quasiment plus besoin de se vacciner on
en est à la troisième et donc israël à
la quatrième dose on nous avait expliqué
que quand on serait vacciné de toute
façon on était sauvée et ben non on
découvre qu'on peut également contaminé
ceux qui ne sont pas alors que nous
mêmes nous sommes vaccinés on nous avait
expliqué que les vagues étaient liés à
de nouveaux variants vous savez il y en
avait un tous les quinze jours un
nouveau variant la le delta il est en
place depuis un bout de temps on n'en
parle plus et pourtant l'épidémie flambe
de nouveau donc en fait les gens qui
sont comme moi qui sont les citoyens de
base qui ne comprennent pas grand chose
à la médecine et qui n'ont pas de
compétences ben c'est eux qu'il faut
écouter parce qu'en fait ils en ont ras
le bol j'ai l'impression que tout ça est
une adaptation est une improvisation
permanente et j'ai commencé en dix ans
la france est fatiguée c'est vraiment le
sentiment que j'ai c'est à dire que
quand vous additionnez les tensions
sociales dans ce pays les tensions
identitaires les tensions communautaires
à celle d'une maladie qui n'arrête pas
d'en finir bas il ya de quoi se dire
jusqu'à quand les français vont
supporter l'intégralité de ce col ce qui
leur arrive alors un autre message
pascal des c'était prévisible voire
prévu depuis le début et je ferai tout
pour garder mon label 0 dose le plus
longtemps possible évidemment ça suscite
des les agacements en tout cas chez les
réfractaires du vexin et même chez les
hôtes arnaud chiche justement vous
grands défenseurs quand même du vaccin
les non-vaccinés y en a je crois près de
6 millions encore en français ce que
peut-être qu'il ne fallait pas les
inciter à aller se faire vacciner
plutôt que de vacciner sans relâche ceux
qui le sont déjà
si madame vous avez raison effectivement
il ya à priori environ 6 millions de
noms vacciner ça représente 15 % c'est
beaucoup et en fait je vais quand même
essayer de répondre à vos deux à vos
deux invités parce qu'ils ont dit tous
les deux des choses très importantes
mais j'ai vraiment besoin de leur
répondre 15 millions 15 % et 6 millions
de patients dont vacciner messieurs 4
sur le plateau vous devez comprendre une
chose très importante c'est que ça
suffit à mettre le système de santé par
terre voilà ça c'est le premier point
ensuite vous savez je pense qu'on ne
fait pas de rappel pour le plaisir les
faits sont têtus la la science qu'on les
aime qu'on les aime pas l'immunologie
qu'on aime qu'on les aime pas il faut
comprendre que l'immunité provoquée par
un vaccin elle n'est pas toujours celle
qu'on voudrait et si on propose un
rappel c'est parce qu'en fait on s'est
rendu compte que
l'immunité baissé après deux injections
et en fait on commence à avoir en
réanimation des malades qui ont bien eu
deux injections mais dont l'immunité de
baisse et du coup il faut un coït g donc
ça c'est le problème c'est un autre
point je voudrais juste su enchaîner sur
le fait de dire que il ya plusieurs
items on a une population qui vieillit
en général on a des patients qui ont
besoin de se faire opérer ont besoin de
se faire soigner de leur cancer ou qui
font un infarctus ils font des arbres
sylvain vasculaires cérébraux je suis en
train de vous parler de la population
qui tombent malades normalement donc on
a des patients âgés qui sont malades on
a des pathologies nombreuses on a une
maladie virale qui est très contagieuse
et qui est capable de provoquer une
contagiosité très importante ce qui fait
que même si le nombre de formes graves
est faible rapporté à l'échelle de la
population
ça représente quand même un nombre
conséquent et on l'a vu dans les vagues
précédentes et surtout enfin peut-être
pour dire oui messieurs 4 sur le plateau
je suis d'accord avec vous tout cela est
quand même un peu dingue le problème
c'est qu'il faut regarder quelles sont
les forces en présence et on a un
système de santé français qui n'a pas
été entretenu pendant trente ans comme
une vieille maison qu'on a laissé mourir
comme une vieille toiture dont on a
laisser s'infiltrer l'eau et puis un
jour on se dit tiens on va faire un
banquier on va faire une grande fête
dans la maison et on se rend compte les
murs les murs on va laisser les rebelles
je crois qu'il y ait même si mme thébaud
d'ailleurs qui rêvent de vous répondre
en vain pour donner évidemment la parole
à la hauteur
évidemment vous êtes mieux placé que
quiconque pour mesurer les dangers qu
une embolisation du système hospitalier
français représente mais j'aimerais
entendre plus de médecins plus de
professeurs de médecine dénoncé un
gouvernement qui a fermé des dizaines de
milliers de lits l'embolisation du
système hospitalier si on avait conservé
les nids d'un système digne de ce nom
dans un pays comme la france on n'en
serait peut-être pas à craindre à cause
de cette nouvelle vague une embolisation
du système hospitalier c'est quand même
ça aussi la résultante d'une politique
est mise en place depuis depuis des
années on peut pas le contester on a
moins de lits donc forcément dès qu'on a
une une épidémie plus ce qu'il faut
traiter au quotidien et que vous fait
merveilleusement dans ce pays bas on est
dépassé par les événements donc que les
professeurs que les médecins de ce pays
donne de la voix manifeste publie des
tribunes en dénonçant ce fait s'il est
juste m'expliquiez les bons oui et non
on vous redonne la parole arnaud chi
juste maxime chievo qui voulez-vous
répondre également qu'elle est
interpellé être entièrement d'accord
avec vous docteur sur le constat est
avec eric revel sur le constat de
délabrement de l'hôpital public ça fait
30 ans qu'on a abandonné l'hôpital
public on a créé les ars en 2009 on leur
demande en fait de libéraliser les
hôpitaux des de rendre efficient les
hôpitaux c'est à dire de supprimer le
service public hospitalier pour le
transformer en un commerce et ça ça
proprement scandaleux on voit revenir
dessus mais la réponse aux qu'ovide elle
est plus complexe que la simple
vaccination oui je suis d'accord sur le
fait il faut proposer une voire inciter
fortement la vaccination aux personnes
âgées aux personnes vulnérables je le
suis moins lorsqu'il s'agit de jeunes
qui sont en pleine santé dont les cas
graves sont quand même assez rare et le
taux de mortalité très faible avec un
vaccin dont on ne connaît pas les
concepts lance sur le long terme mais
surtout ce que j'aurais apprécié cette
le gouvernement premièrement
réinvestissent dans l'hôpital public
réellement il me semble qu'il a fermé à
peu près mille huit cents lits depuis
depuis le début de la crise et
deuxièmement qu'il a une politique à
long terme notamment vis-à-vis des
comorbidités je voyais ce matin chez vos
confrères de différentes chaînes
télévision qui disait que aujourd'hui la
saturation des hôpitaux c'est
globalement des personnes qui ont des
comorbidités notamment des personnes
obèses qu'est ce qu'on a fait depuis
deux ans pour lutter contre l'obésité
qu'est ce qu'on a fait en termes de
santé publique pour que les gens se met
au sport pour que les gens se soignent
pour que dans un an mais non mais voilà
des gens d'affaires mais salle de sport
on les a confiné on les a encouragés à
rester chez eux qu'est ce qu'on a fait
en fait en réalité pour lutter sur le
long terme parce que c'est ce qui va
nous arriver on va traîner avec des
épidémies pendant 10 15 20 ans qu'est ce
qu'on a fait pour apprendre à vivre avec
le virus pour avoir une réponse
optimiste et ça on ne l'a pas eue et
c'est ce que je regrette fortement
arnaud chichoumé voulait peut-être
répondre ah ben je pense que je voulais
vous montrer quand même au et allez-y
alesi avant de vous montrer ce que font
les meyrinois deux invités au premier
invité monsieur mais vous savez je mène
le même combat que vous et aujourd'hui
moi je mène un combat au sein du
collectif sont en danger depuis 17 mois
pour essayer de me battre pour faire
comprendre aux français que leur système
de santé est insuffisant et j'aimerais
que les professeurs emboîtent le pas
mais en fait les professeurs vous savez
probablement que idéologiquement ce sont
des gens qui étaient un peu proche du
pouvoir est en fait les gens ont été
très contemplatif et aujourd'hui encore
monsieur je suis ringardisé dans mon
combat il faut le savoir parce que vous
savez en france les médecins ils disent
rien quoi et donc on est on est
contemplatif et en fait mais oui ils
devraient tous condamnés alors il ya des
tribunes il y en a mais y'en a pas assez
et en tout cas il faut il faut gueuler
et marteler le message et il suffit de
voir si la santé s'invite dans le débat
présidentiel
vous connaissez la réponse on n'en parle
pas on glisse excusez moi d'être
vulgaire on glisse la merde sous le
tapis mais le problème c'est que le
tapis déborde et ça il faut des gens
pour le dire alors moi je le dis et
alors ensuite à alors à votre autre
collègue monsieur l'avocat je suis en
partie d'accord avec vous je vais le
dire autrement est-ce que la priorité
aujourd'hui c'est la troisième dose ou
alors c'est peut-être la première dose
des gens qui sont pas vaccinés et pour
vous avez raison les chercher cela mais
avant il ya vingt personnes âgées les
pistes mais oui eh ben oui tout à fait
c'est un manque dans les propositions du
ministre aujourd'hui il faut créer un
système pour aller chez les gens qui se
sont eux qui se font pas vacciner parce
qu'ils sont trop âgés et il faut il
pouvoir insiste itinérant et ça c'est à
l'état de l'organiser mais non
l'organisent pas il ya des gens
aujourd'hui connaissent pas dr inouïe
sont pas capables de l'utiliser et ça et
ça saoule et c'est un vrai problème
c'est un vrai problème en tout cas merci
arnaud chiche de nous avoir donné votre
point de vue en d'accueil plus tard un
autre invité sur l'école je voudrais
vous faire regarder quand même ce que
font nos voisins européens bien qu'on le
sache mais quand même ça rafraîchit la
mémoire l'autriche qui reconfirme
totalement les non-vaccinés pays-bas
fermeture bar resto à 20h slovaquie
confinement des non vaccinés également
l'allemagne c'est pareil avec aussi de
nouvelles mesures pour l'italie
aujourd'hui maxime thibeault quand même
est-ce qu'on n'est pas un peu sévère je
me fais l'avocat du diable évidemment
ici avec la france qui bon an mal an son
sort avec peut-être un peu moins de deux
mesures liberticides en tout cas quoi
qu'il arrive ce virus y tue les libertés
dans tous les sens moi je pense que
c'est l'occident qui est malade c'est le
modèle occidental on a fait de l'hygiène
le grand principe et il a une
conséquence et celui du principe de
précaution et par précaution il faut
tout interdire faut tout faire mais on a
la chance encore en france ne pas être à
ce point là parce qu'on à l'élection
présidentielle qui arrive l'année
prochaine je pense qu'un manuel macro
envie de gagner étonnamment donc on
n'est pas encore tombé là-dedans mais la
réalité c'est là qu'elle s'était qu'un
virus qui tue moins d'un pour cent de la
population
on est capable de supprimer toute
activité économique on est capable de
supprimer la vie sociale je pense qu'à
une vraie question philosophique vous
avez andré comte sponville à a écrit sur
ce sujet il a beaucoup parlé c'est une
question sur laquelle on n'intervient
jamais j'aurais aimé moi qu'à
l'assemblée nationale on se pose cette
belle question de société de savoir mais
comment on vit avec un virus qui commet
dans ce monde où on a de nouvelles
crises où on a cette tendance hygiéniste
on doit saisir ces nouveaux enjeux et on
l'a pas alors c'est vrai qu'on est dans
un pays tout à fait particulier faut
jamais oublier que jacques chirac a fait
inscrire dans la constitution fraises le
principe de précaution ça veut dire
qu'on prend des précautions sur la
précaution de la précaution qu'on avait
prise avant ou en même temps qu'ils sont
traînés devant la porte de juste pour
rire et non mais je suis la corbeille
sera ciblé précaution fola bien l'avoir
en tête parce que ça explique peut-être
les mesures moi ce qui me ce qui me
fascine c'est que personne n'est capable
de prévoir l'avenir pas plus
gouvernement que le virus lui même et
quand vous êtes très optimiste
finalement en disant bas on est un peu
moins liberticide peut-être ailleurs
2 les deux remarques d'urmatt la
première c'est que personne ne sait ce
que va devenir cette vague pas plus le
gouvernement que moi ou que nos
spécialistes donc personne ne peut vous
dire qu'il y aura pas un rond
confinement personne n'en sait rien tout
ça va crescendo ça peut être demain
c'est la guerre c'est la guerre c'est la
guerre et puis deuxième chose que je
remarque en europe c'est que toutes ces
mesures elles aboutissent quand même
vous l'avez vu aux pays-bas à des
émeutes en autriche à des manifestations
extrêmement forte brett hull pour ça en
guadeloupe sur ça que quand je vous dis
la france s'ennuie comparaison n'est pas
raison avec ce qui s'est passé il ya
quelques décennies mais on est quand
même potentiellement en europe et en
france sur un baril de poudre alors de
messages qui nous parviennent à la
question est ce qu'on est dans une
spirale infernale
oui pour laurent ça fait deux ans déjà
qu'on est dans une spirale infernale on
en sortira la question est quand et
comment nate qui nous dit on demande
toujours plus pour au final retourner
avec case départ je comprends qu'il
faille faire l'effort mais on fait tant
d'efforts pour se retrouver à cette case
départ ça pose évidemment maxime chez
hbo la question de l'acceptation de la
population la question de l'adhésion et
la question peut-être de la démocratie
ah oui alors il ya une vraie question
derrière ces l'accoutumance aux mesures
de restriction les les beaucoup de
professeurs de droit je pense à anne
levade qui ceux qui se posent des
questions en dix ans mais le problème
c'est que plus on est habitué aux
mesures de restriction bas plus on s'y
accoutume et moins d'efforts devant
sortir je me souviens que quand le
gouvernement avait annoncé dans la rue
on pouvait retirer le masque et des
français l'avaient dit mais non c'est
atroce en art tombé malade alors qu'on
avait aucune preuve est qu'on en a
aucune que le masque dans l'arbre dans
la rue est utile donc moi ce qui
m'inquiète en fait sur le long terme
c'est cette installation des mesures et
le fait qu'on va vivre comme ça dans un
état qui a abandonné sa liberté parce
que quand on regarde dans le rétroviseur
depuis 20-30 ans on a énormément de
liberté sur énormément de sujets qui
nous ont été réduites sur l'opinion sur
le sécuritaire sur la liberté
d'expression je voulais dire sur la
santé sur sur la liberté d'aller et
venir et c'est hyper dangereux faut être
hyper méfiant avec ça parce que ce qui
se passe en france c'est que on peut
vous priver de liberté les français ne
sont pas contre la sécurité par contre
ce qui les inquiète fortement c'est
l'injustice dès que vous tombez sur
l'injustice et bien là il ya une révolte
il ya un réveil qui a lieu et j'ai peur
de cela si on va trop loin alors autres
mesures annoncées aujourd'hui il n'y
aura finalement plus de fermetures de
classes systématique dès le premier cas
de decaux vide à l'école c'est une
nouvelle mesure qui réjouit certains
parents qui ont un petit peu marre
d'avoir la garde forcée des enfants à
domicile n'est ce pas depuis la rentrée
on va voir ce qu'on pense les
enseignants on retrouve en direct arno
fabre bonsoir arno fabre vous êtes
enseignant donc administrateur national
des stylos rouges comment le corps
enseignants accueillent ces mesures
passent autant on accentue la sévérité
sur le reste mais l'école et le primaire
çà s'allège un petit peu
abbas à s'allège même beaucoup et on
peut dire les choses sérieusement là
c'est à dire que curieusement l'épidémie
explose et les mesures qui pourraient
aller contre l'épidémie sont levés donc
on casse le thermomètre pour ne pas voir
les malades donc où il n'a effectivement
il a incontestablement cette décision
apparaît assez insensé il faut dire les
choses arrêtez les fermetures de classes
ça peut comme vous l'avez dit arranger
certains parents mais je pense que ça
n'arrangera pas du tout le pays
ça vaut aux états unis crevel cette
mesure lors c'est vrai qu'il faut aussi
préciser qu'on responsabilise davantage
les familles qui vont devoir cette fois
ci donné un test prouver que leur enfant
n'est pas malade ils vont quand même
devoir se faire tester des clercs un cas
positif
de lâcher du lest sur les écoles c'était
la bonne chose oui enfin je vais vous
dire pourquoi enfin il faut voir ce qui
s'est passé réprimer ce qui s'est passé
en 2020 en 2020 on a tout sacrifié à la
santé sans doute une bonne chose
qu'est-ce qui est le plus précieux que
la santé et on a mis en bottes
l'économie en fait ne vous y trompez pas
à mon avis monsieur fait fausse route ça
va énormément changé pour le pays
pourquoi parce que des parents qui ne
sont pas obligés de récupérer leurs
enfants et donc de les garder à la
maison c'est des parents qui travaillent
qui sont ou en télétravail tranquille
chez eux ou qui vont dans leur bureau ou
dans leurs usines donc en réalité on
voit bien ce qu'est en train de faire le
gouvernement sait que vous êtes passés
d'une récession - 8 % en 2020 avec le
confinement strict est terrible a
aujourd'hui une croissance qui repart et
je pense que le gouvernement fait plus
le choix de l'économie en prenant ces
décisions que celui de la santé donc en
réalité pour la croissance économique et
ceux qui pensent qu'il ya du
ruissellement et que la croissance est
une bonne chose au contraire permettre
aux parents de laisser leurs enfants
dans une école dans une classe même s'il
ya un ou deux cas avérés c'est
l'assurance que l'économie va continuer
sur sa lancée de progression arno fabre
justement sur ce que je disais il faut
quand même prouvé qu'on n'est pas
positif ils vont devoir donner des tests
ces enfants et ces familles oui mais je
pense que monsieur revel a tout à fait
raison c'est à dire que ce qui est
certain c'est que là on voit que la
priorité n'est pas sur la santé mais
bien sûr la machine économique disons
les choses c'est à dire que la priorité
du gouvernement et nounkeu tour est
normal et d'ailleurs je rejoins là
dessus même si nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur tout maître thiébaut
puisque il soulève une question
essentielle il dit que depuis deux ans
finalement on ne prévoit pas or là on se
retrouve exactement face à une situation
on a l'impression qu'on improvise
et donc foncièrement le problème est là
c'est à dire que finalement même si nous
ne sommes pas d'accord mais m thiébaut
sur ce qu'il faudrait faire moi je pense
qu' il faudrait dès 2000 groupe notre
groupe les stylos rouges pense qu'il
faudrait aussi parler d'une prime de
risque importante pour les enseignants
parce qu'en l'occurrence ils sont mis
quel que soit leur âge cette voie si la
présidentielle un maquereau
soignante allez-y vous allez les avoir
faits c'est ce qu'on fait vous avez
raison on hamm est foncièrement un des
problèmes par exemple c'est que on a
quand même beaucoup de collègues qui
tombe malade a dû qu'ovide est bon parce
que les élèves très souvent sont
contaminés 1 et sont contaminés ensemble
ces lambeaux et résultats résultat ses
collègues quand même se retrouve avec
des arrêts de travail qui leur coûte
cher on vous rappelle que le jour de
carence est maintenu on rappelle que
pour aller faire un test pour vérifier
si on a le président ou pas on doit
quand même bah du coup à prendre un à un
arrêt et si on appelle coded paf l'agent
des carences tombe comme une journée de
grève 1 donc il ya beaucoup de collègues
dans les faits dans l'éducation quel que
soit d'ailleurs leur statut professeurs
personnels de direction encadrant simple
c'est-à-dire surveillants et cetera à us
h tous ces gens-là signalement et là il
se retrouve à devoir se retenir de se
faire tester par ce qu'on nous explique
qu'on va être testé dans les
établissements excusez moi mais c'est de
la blague c'est vrai que ça n'arrive on
l'a donné le mot de la fin est la
réponse pardonnez moi parce qu'on arrive
à la fin a maxime thibault alors c'est
vrai que c'était salivaire savait pas
vraiment fonctionné à la campagne de
tests salivaires dans les écoles mais
monsieur fais le plus beau métier du
monde c'est celui de transmettre le
savoir et je pense qu'il faut pas casser
la chaîne de transmission c'est pour ça
que je suis contre la fermeture des
écoles oui il faut vous protéger il faut
mettre tous les dispositifs qu'on peut
pour protéger les à la fois les élèves
et puis les enseignants mais il faut
surtout pas casser cela parce qu'en 2020
en fait on a sauvé la santé physique
mais au détriment de la santé mentale
des élèves parce que les élèves ils ont
besoin d'apprendre les enfants ils ont
besoin de vivre en société et ça on
l'abandonné c'est pour ça que je suis
content la fermeture des écoles je suis
affreusement compte la femme noyée on
apprend à vivre avec le virus fina pour
qu'on apprenne et pour qu'on apprenne à
vivre avec le virus que le ministre
blanc caire avait très bien fait de se
battre contre la fermeture des écoles à
l'époque parce que une société qui ne
transmet pas le savoir c'est une société
qui se perd et vraiment je suis d'accord
avec votre combat pour votre prime tout
ça bon ok très bien mais n'oubliez pas
que vous faites le plus beau métier du
monde
ayez ce premier terme en bouche c'est
pour ça qu'il faut protéger nos élèves
les personnels et leurs familles eric
revel un petit mot de la fin peut-être
pour vous la vaccination justement
puisqu'on est dans les enfants
n'ont pas vous pas vous les enfants ma
vie 5 11 ans ça a été approuvé
aujourd'hui par l' agence européenne des
médicaments alors ça ensemble ça va être
un débat houleux jusqu'où va aller
l'acception c'est le vaccin pour les
enfants c'est un peu comme les éoliennes
les énergies renouvelables c'est à dire
qu'on est tous plus ou moins pour mais
condition que soient pas devant ses
fenêtres lance moi j'ai à dire la
vaccination c'est un fils qui est dans
ces âges là bas depuis longtemps je me
pose la question et je suis pas certain
du tout d'avoir envie de vouloir le
faire vacciner de dire personne ne sait
rien tout le monde vous dit tout et son
contraire et tout ça quand même
angoissant pour les parents que nous
sommes tous donc on va voir comment ils
vont nous avancer ce nouveau débat et
peut-être que il au biberon aussi
peut-être savez ce jour on demandera aux
proviseurs ou directeurs d'école de
contrôler le pass sanitaires de leurs
élèves et leur là là on sera dans le mur
à mon avis merci beaucoup à tous d'être
warnault favre à arnaud chiche qui nous
a donc quitté tout à l'heure maxime
thiébaut et eric revel merci d'avoir été
avec ue et en espagne 1 cette fois les
les chiffres du comité sont eux aussi à
la hausse malgré un taux de vaccination
élevé en conséquence les régions
prennent des mesures à l'image de la
catalogne qui impose le passage du ter
n'a encore pour rentrer dans les
établissements plus de précision avec
notre correspondante à barcelone
clémentine laurent
lakovic 19 remonte en espagne ici en
catalogne les hospitalisations pour
infection à la coved 19 ont grimpé de
plus de 60% seulement deux semaines et
la barre des 100 patients admis en
réanimation a été dépassé alors pour
faire face à ce qui ressemble à une
nouvelle vague le gouvernement catalan
prend des mesures et là notamment décidé
d'imposer le pass sanitaires pour entrer
dans de nouveaux établissements alors
pour l'instant il était déjà demandé
pour entrer dans les discothèques dans
les bar dansant pour les célébrations où
l'on danse et aussi pour les concerts
mais à partir de ce vendredi et bien il
faudra aussi le présenter pour entrer
dans les restaurants les bars les cafés
les salles de sport et le sera aussi
nécessaire pour effectuer des visites
dans les hôpitaux ou les maisons de
retraite alors il faut savoir que la
catalogne est la première région en
espagne a imposé le pass sanitaires pour
ce type d'établissement les restaurants
de barcelone vont donc devoir contrôler
les certificats de leurs clients et
c'est une première je vous propose
d'écouter quelques professionnels du
secteur
cela fait très peu de temps que nous
avons appris la nouvelle et nous n'avons
pas encore organisé un système pour le
mettre en place cela nous crée un
problème on va devoir mettre une
personne devant la porte pour contrôler
tout ça nous n'avons pas encore parlé
avec l'équipe mais il faut le gérer le
plus rapidement possible et trouver une
solution pour pouvoir exiger se passa ni
terre ça va nous créer des problèmes
avec des clients parce qu'il ya des
habitués que nous connaissons et qui ne
vont pas être d'accord
ça va nous créer des situations sociales
difficiles
nous allons devoir avoir beaucoup de
patience pour faire comprendre aux
clients qu'ils ne peuvent pas être à
l'intérieur s'ils n'ont pas le vaccin ou
le pass sanitaires nous pouvons leur
proposer de se mettre en terrasse nous
avons de la place mais en hiver c'est un
peu compliqué
nous sommes obligés de prendre ces
mesures qui sont assez drastiques on ne
nous donne pas les moyens pour ça donc
normalement il y un bon pourcentage de
vacciner ça ne devrait pas poser trop de
problèmes lessard est préjudiciable car
ça risque de se traduire par une baisse
de l'affluence en finale
[Musique]
si la situation sanitaire se dégrade
encore le gouvernement espagnol conseils
à ces régions de fermer les restaurants
à 23h les discothèques à une heure du
matin mais pour l'instant l'exécutif
catalan ne compte pas appliquer d'autres
mesures le pass sanitaire est pour le
moment imposé pour deux semaines le
gouvernement catalan verra ensuite s'il
ne prolonge ou pas en fonction de la
situation sanitaire dans la région en
attendant le gouvernement appelle à la
vaccination est ici la troisième dose et
notamment ouverte uniquement pour les
personnes de moins 70 ans en maison de
retraite ou les personnes à risque
auraient des restrictions qui se
renforce également ailleurs en europe
slovaquie autriche ukraine italie ou
encore pays-bas l'étau se resserre
autour des non vaccinés de quoi
provoquer la colère d'une partie de la
population tour d'horizon avec samira
chaabi le visage est grave le ton
martial hier le premier ministre italien
a alerté sur la dégradation de la
situation sanitaire et un serrage de vis
s'impose
nous constatons une situation très grave
en dehors de l'italie dans des pays qui
sont nos voisins nous constatons aussi
que notre situation en italie se dégrade
lentement mais sûrement
comme comme nous le savons tous le
laissez-passer vert est accordée sous
trois conditions différentes la première
étant une vaccination
la deuxième étant la guérison et la
troisième étant un test négatif soit
antigénique soit moléculaire étant donné
qu'en cette période
nous assistons à une augmentation de la
pandémie et à une situation
internationale complexe du 6 décembre au
15 janvier
nous introduisons un type de laisser
passer vers plus fort ce qui signifie
que pour l'obtenir seuls deux cas
restent valables on peut obtenir un
certificat soit après une vaccination
soit après la guérison
des mesures qui génère de la crispation
crispation qui se fait entendre dans la
rue comme ici aux pays bas le pays a été
le théâtre de plusieurs nuits d'émeute
depuis vendredi dernier 173 personnes
ont déjà été interpellées et l'exécutif
n'en démord pas le gouvernement
néerlandais a déjà annoncé ce lundi que
des mesures semblables à un confinement
pourrait voir le jour si les
restrictions actuelles n'étaient pas
respectées ce qui fait craindre une
nouvelle poussée de fièvre anti
restrictions
non je ne vois vraiment pas de solution
tant que le gouvernement continue de
prendre des mesures sanitaires je ne
vois pas de solution venir et j'ai peur
qu'il y ait plus d'émeutes situation
semblable en ukraine où des
mobilisations anti mesures sanitaires se
sont tenues dans le viseur des
contestataires l'inégalité de traitement
entre vacciner et non vaccinés
aujourd'hui il y a des privilèges pour
les vacciner pour les autorités et des
restrictions pour les non vaccinés pour
les personnes en bonne santé pour qu'il
est interdit de visiter des lieux
publics pour qu'il est interdit de se
rendre dans une autre région si elles ne
sont pas vaccinés cela viole la
constitution de l'ukraine
ceux qui prennent de telles décisions ce
devrait être en prison pas ceux qui
défendent nos droits constitutionnels
la contagion at-il restriction a aussi
gagné la slovaquie ou un confinement
partiel de deux semaines a été approuvé
par le gouvernement
vendredi dernier la police a dû faire
usage de gaz lacrymogènes pour disperser
une manifestation devenue incontrôlable
deux ans après le début de la pandémie
le regain de contamination en europe
fait craindre à l'om est-ce sept cent
mille morts supplémentaires d'ici le
printemps
après un regain de l'épidémie sur le
vieux continent malgré un taux de
vaccination en augmentation parmi les
laboratoires qui ont développé le sérum
anti qu'ovide évidemment pfizer la
société américaine qui affirme que des
documents liés à plusieurs de ces
vaccins aurait été dérobé un faiseur
intenté un procès contre l'une de ses
employées qui aurait donc des données
ultra sensibles en sa possession on en
parle tout de suite avec notre
correspondant à washington tom abonnés
bonsoir thomas la salariée qui serait
notamment en partie avec des fichiers
liées aux os et rome antique au vide on
imagine à quel point ces précieux par
les temps qui courent
oui on parle d'une fuite massive de
documents puisque selon la plainte
déposée par pfizer cet ancien salarié
serait parti en emportant avec elle plus
de 12000 fichiers elle s'appelle chung
xiao li elle aurait donc transférer des
données depuis son ordinateur fournis
par pfizer à destination d'un système de
stockage personnel en ligne lorsque
l'entreprise s'en aperçoit sept salariés
fait d'abord mine de coopérer mais il
s'agit en réalité d'une ruse en tout cas
selon les éléments avancés par pfizer
écouter
en quittant l'entreprise elle a tenté de
brouiller les pistes à plusieurs
reprises elle est allée jusqu'à fournir
à l'équipe de sécurité de pfizer un
ordinateur portable leur laissant croire
à pfizer que c'était celui qu'elle avait
utilisé pour télécharger les 12000
fichiers de son compte google drive
alors évidemment la question que tout le
monde se pose c'est de savoir quelles
sont les informations auxquelles cette
salariée a pu avoir accès alors il faut
comprendre que cette personne était
employé chez pfizer depuis 15 ans à un
poste relativement haut placés et dans
sa plainte l'entreprise fader reconnaît
elle-même la sensibilité des
informations potentiellement dérobés par
cet ancien salarié là encore je propose
d'écouter
étant donné son rôle et ses
responsabilités en tant que directrice
associée des statistiques madame lee
avait accès à du contenu hautement
confidentielles exclusifs et des
informations relevant du secret
industriel
concernant de nombreux vaccins et des
médicaments incluant le vaccin contre le
coc vite 19
et puis évidemment l'autre question
c'est de savoir ce que cette ancienne
salariée compte faire de toutes ces
informations kaiser avance l'hypothèse
du fait que cet ancien salarié puisse
rejoindre un concurrent de pfizer
puisque le géant pharmaceutique explique
qu'il ait eu beaucoup de tentatives de
recrutement en cours des derniers mois
par la justice américaine va devoir se
prononcer sur le fond de cette affaire
ce sera certainement dans le courant du
mois de décembre en attendant une juge
de la ville de san diego a décidé
d'interdire temporairement lusage de ses
secrets commerciaux par cet ancien
salarié merci thomas bonnet pour ces
précisions en direct de washington
la crise migratoire à nouveau au centre
du bras de fer entre paris et londres en
cause un nouveau drame hier dans les
manches avec le naufrage d'un bateau de
fortune 27 migrants sont décédés
partie de dunkerque il tentait de
rejoindre les côtes britanniques leur
embarcation a vraisemblablement été
percuté par un cargo 5 passeurs présumés
ont été arrêtés la france annonce une
règne en ce dimanche à calais avec
plusieurs ministres européens en charge
de l'immigration et la commission
européenne pour renforcer la coopération
et valérie la bonne
dignité respect et coopération tels sont
les mots d' emmanuel macron ce jeudi en
réponse à boris johnson après la mort de
dix sept hommes sept femmes et trois
jeunes migrants en mer le chef de l'état
a rappelé à l'ordre le premier ministre
britannique
le président de la république a insisté
sur la nécessité d'agir dans la dignité
dans le respect et dans un esprit de
coopération efficace s'agissant de vies
humaines il attend des britanniques
qu'ils coopèrent pleinement et qu'ils
s'abstiennent d'instrumentaliser une
situation dramatique à des fins
politiques un message qui intervient
après celui du premier ministre
britannique mercredi soir à l'issue
d'une réunion interministérielle
boris johnson exhorté la france à
prendre ses responsabilités
nous avons eu des difficultés à
persuader certains de nos partenaires en
particulier les français d'agir à la
hauteur de la situation
mais je comprends les difficultés
auxquelles tous les pays sont confrontés
est ce que nous voulons maintenant c'est
faire plus ensemble la question
migratoire débat sans fin entre la
france et le royaume uni qui se
rejettent la faute depuis plusieurs mois
dans le même temps les tentatives de
traversée de la manche à bord de petites
embarcations se sont multipliés et les
records journaliers ne cesse de tomber
dernier en date le 11 novembre avec
l'arrivée de 1185 migrants sur le sol
ans mais sur les dix premiers mois de
l'année londres indiquent que vingt-deux
mille migrants ont réussi la traversée
et avant mercredi soir le bilan
s'élevait à trois morts et quatre
disparus en 2021 et pour en parler nous
sommes avec alexandre delval
géopolitologue docteur en histoire
contemporaine co auteur du livre la
mondialisation dangereuse vers le
déclassement de l'occident aux éditions
l'artilleur bonsoir alexandre delval
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france on le voit la
france inquiète invités ministres
européens et la commission européenne à
une réunion dimanche plus que jamais
cette affaire illustre l'absence criante
de solutions communes pour l'instant
tout cas entre ces deux pays la france
et le royaume uni en particulier depuis
le break site oui depuis le break si tu
savais que le bric site a été provoquée
par justement une volonté de ce pays de
contrôler les flux migratoires qui sont
rendus incontrôlable par les mesures
diverses et variées des instances
mondiale et surtout européenne notamment
qui ont demandé à tous les pays
européens depuis des années de
dépénaliser la migration clandestine par
définition la migration clandestine est
hors la loi normalement c'est même eux
c'est quelque chose qui peut susciter
même l'emprisonnement depuis des années
le fait d'avoir dépénaliser la migration
clandestine
gordon un appel d'air énorme et en plus
on a totalement dépénaliser ceux qui
aident les migrants clandestins n'est
pas comme le fameux passeur des
alpes-maritimes et maritime qui a pris
dans sa camionnette qu'elle eyquem
carrément aller les chercher alors
parfois l'enfer est pavé de bonnes
intentions le problème c'est que ça fait
le jeu des passeurs qui se font payer
entre 5000 euros en méditerranée à 15000
pour ceux qui viennent de très loin
jusqu'à l'angleterre parce qu'en fait il
un parcours migratoire souvent liées à
des phénomènes de délinquance ou de
marché noir donc en fait il a tout un il
est tout un tissu autour de la migration
clandestine qui a l'air d'être presque
christique tout à fait innocente il ya
des réalités de délinquance derrière
voir par même de sécurité en terme de
terrorisme et enfin sécurité pour les
personnes qui traversent sur des bateaux
de fortune avec ce drame qui s'est passé
ces jours ci mais ça arrive ailleurs au
aussi aimé tout ça ce n'est pas la faute
de l'état
français ou en anglais c'est la faute de
déré de réseau international qui ont pu
faire ce qu'ils voulaient pendant des
années et aussi de l'assistanat en
europe qui donne l'illusion que l'europe
serait un eldorado et ya plein de gens
qui sont prêts à risquer leur vie dans
des parcours absolument terrible pour
arriver à cet eldorado qui en fait n'en
est plus un depuis longtemps c'était ma
question vous dit qu'ils étaient un
eldorado ce n'est vraiment plus le cas
aujourd'hui ces migrants finalement font
fausse route de vouloir s'entêter à
venir suffit de voir les villes en
france notamment paris mais aussi quand
je vais en italie moi j'étais frappé
depuis qui a été ces problèmes aussi à
lampedusa les villes même du nord de
l'italie qui était un peu comme la
suisse sont devenus surtout quand vous
êtes dans les gares dans tout le nord de
l'italie vous voyez de véritables
réserves de clandestins qui errent les
pauvres dans les rues qui n'ont pas
d'emploi qui sont plus ou moins qui ont
plus ou moins des subsides des ong ou
des mairies mais qui sont un petit peu
comme ça a lâché dame nature souvent qui
sont récupérés par des réseaux de
dealers par des réseaux de trafic ou de
marché noir l'italie d'ailleurs on peut
dire que ce phénomène a expliqué la
montée du populisme en italie comme dans
d'autres pays donc c'est un problème qui
n'est pas que français et je pense qu'on
ne peut pas accabler uniquement le la
france pour ce qui s'est passé c'est un
phénomène européen qui est dû au laxisme
européen qui donne cet appel d'air et
justement on remonte à loin mais la
chute du mur de berlin était supposé
conforter une forme de notions de
mondialisation heureuse justement pour
le faire un jeu de mots avec votre livre
avec dès la fin des barrières physiques
la consécration suite en deux de
l'europe la crise migratoire clairement
elle est en train de devenir le pire
ennemi de cet idéal européen plus que le
pire ennemi c'est quelque chose qui est
utilisé par les prédateurs externe à
l'union européenne on l'a vu avec le
cash and co récemment mais on l'a vu
beaucoup avec erdogan on le voyait jadis
avec la libye l'italie et l'europe payé
la libye très cher à l'époque de kadhafi
pour maintenir les c'est une véritable
arme pour des pays qui eux n'ont aucune
culpabilité et aux hehe et aucun
scrupule qui parfois mais mitraille les
migrants comme on l'a vu même dans des
pays du maghreb mais qui savent que
comme les européens veulent se donner
bonne conscience et ont quand même les
droits de l'homme au sommet de leur
système juridique et constitutionnel ils
savent que cette culpabilisation
cette europe complexe et kike qui
n'osent pas véritablement maintenir ses
frontières et qui est contre les murs
les murs et le mot le plus vulgaire
aujourd'hui eh bien ils savent ça peut
être une arme on va le renvoyer des
migrants ou leur faire croire qu'on va
là où les menaces et de les submerger et
ils plieront c'est comme ça qu erdogan a
récolté 6 milliards et 5 de deux
promesses de 2,2 d'euros en échange d'un
soi-disant contrôle des flux migratoires
qu'il a à moitié respecter d'ailleurs
voilà c'est une arme pour les prédateurs
extérieur cette mauvaise conscience
européenne et c'est pour ça que dans ce
livre la mondialisation dangereuse avec
soppelsa le disons que l'europe est le
dindon de la farce d'une mondialisation
qui n'est pas du tout heureuse qui a des
bons côtés mais aussi des côtés mauvais
les mafias le terrorisme international
l'islamisme les phénomènes de migration
clandestine il lié à la délinquance ce
sont des phénomènes qui ont été
facilités par la mondialisation et la
mafia où les mafias sont derrière cette
ces parcours migratoire qui je le répète
pourquoi les gens veulent aller en
angleterre parce qu'il ya tout un
circuit mondial ils achètent cas pour
15000 euros non seulement une traversée
mais une destination il ya quelqu'un qui
vend peut-être des téléphones ou des
tapis ou un
hôtel ou autre chose ou carrément des
dealers qui l'attendent à londres où
qu'ils attendent en écosse voyez donc
tout cela c'est les appels d'air lié à
cette mondialisation heureuse qui a fait
que l'europe a cru qu'elle pouvait
s'ouvrir qu'on était tous frères que la
mondialisation étant justement
nécessairement heureuse n'y avait pas
besoin de se protéger les questions
justement la mondialisation ou une forme
d'idéologie sur sept mondialistes
ce que vous votre question est très
important parce que il y à la
mondialisation qui est un phénomène
neutre comme nous le moins dans ce livre
et son interprétation idéologique qui
elle et le mondialisme cette idée selon
laquelle il y aurait plus besoin de
frontières et les murs c'est horrible du
coup les juges c'est pas bien non plus
du coup en fait c'est le projet des
multinationales et des gars femme
détruire les ordres étatiques pour en
fait avoir l'ordre de ce que andré
bercoff mon ami journaliste appelle les
racailles d'en haut c'est à dire des
réalités multinationales qui n'ont qui
n'aiment pas les juges qui n'aiment pas
les impôts qui n'aiment pas les
frontières et en fait derrière se
mondialise il ya des intérêts de la
grande finance et de certaines grandes
entreprises multinationales et en fait
on habille ce projet mondialiste avec
des belles paroles avec la figure du
migrant christique avec eux mais parfois
les autres c'est l'écologie mais en fait
il y à un véritable projet mondialiste
qui n'est pas du tout la mondialisation
la preuve on le montre dans ce livre la
chine elle elle voit dans la
mondialisation non pas le mondialisme la
preuve qu on doit enlever les frontières
mais elle voit dans la mondialisation un
tremplin pour en ne trône pas du tout le
dindon de la farce et l'utiliser au
contraire pour exporter sa puissance
pour son intérêt et pour son
nationalisme en fait ceux qui s'en tire
le mieux dans la mondialisation c'est ce
qu'ils n'ont pas du tout une lecture
sans frontiérisme chez les
souverainistes c'est la chine
nationaliste maoïste c'est la turquie
d'erdogan c'est la malaisie l'indonésie
des pays identitaire et souverainistes
et pas du tout complexé et le seul qui
est complexé qui en a une lecture
idyllique c'est l'europe l'europe
bisounours land où que dans le livre on
l'appelle logement objet politique non
identifié
est ce que l'europe arrive à un moment
charnière parce que vous l'avez dit à
des idéaux on n'aime pas les murs il
importe en mille kilomètres qui ont été
érigés au gré des décrit ces dernières
années on voit encore qu'elle ne paiera
pas pour le mur en pologne mais il ya
aussi de l'autre côté les opinions
publiques qui sont de plus en plus
contre notamment l'immigration le voit
dans les sondages encore la
présidentielle française ce sont des
tests qui ont du succès ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir à un moment clé dans
peu de temps alors ce qui est dommage
c'est que l'immigration qui a été
longtemps
non contrôlée finalement a nui à des
belles causes que sont
l'accueil devrait réfugiés qui fuient
devrait guère et ça c'est dommage parce
que si on avait maîtriser les flux
migratoires si on n'avait pas laissé des
flux absolument un contrôle et changer
les fils d'une amie de plusieurs villes
européennes peut-être que l'opinion
publique serait moins contre un
véritable demandeurs d'asile un
véritable réfugiés qui fuient le vrai
guerre mais malheureusement cette
immigration incontrôlée essentiellement
économiques qui détourne le droit
d'asile à mon avis a nui au véritable
droit d'asile et ça c est extrêmement
regrettable parce que l'opinion publique
n'est pas inhumain si si vraiment il y
avait de vrais demandeurs d'asile si on
savait ne pas tout mélanger je pense que
l'opinion publique et et humaniste mais
ce qui ne veut pas c'est ce détournement
aujourd'hui que ça soit les flux de 2,2
d'étudiants les flux de demandeurs
d'asile de réfugiés politiques et aussi
le regroupement familial qui est
totalement incontrôlée il y à un
détournement de règles des parcelles qui
sont devenus des instruments pour en
fait contourner les lois et pour forcer
la main aux pays d'accueil qui sont
obligés de recevoir des populations
massive et incontrôlée qui au départ
aurait pu être acceptable et est intégré
si elle était restée un certain chiffre
mais à partir d'un certain chiffre on à
la civilisation qui nous revient au
galop c'est à dire on ne peut pas un
moment intégré et assimilés quand il ya
un nombre qui est incontrôlée et donc
quelque part trop d'immigration tu
l'immigration la bonne immigration c'est
celle qui est contrôlé et il faut
revenir à mon avis à un peu à ce café
l'australie c'est à dire cesser l'appel
d'air il y aura moins de morts en mer si
on tari les flux à la source avec des
accords avec les pays d'origine aussi
mais aussi par des phénomènes
sécuritaire le chef de la marine
italienne disait récemment que si on
laissait la main libre à la marine
italienne sans faire de mort s'en tirait
bien sûr sur des braves gens eh bien on
pourrait dissuader les départs et du
coup y aurait plus des milliers de gens
qui kiffent qui rêvent de passer la
frontière et de la mer pardon et qui se
noierait en mer mais alexandre dellal
comment on fait en europe parce que on
est 27 désormais on l'a vu d'ailleurs en
2015 angela merkel qui a accepté ces
migrants du coup d'autres pillon ont dû
suivre avec souvent l'opposition des
pays plus à l'est comment se mettront
d'accord est ce que l'europe est
condamnée à échouer alors tout le
problème de l'europe c'est que elle n'a
pas réussi à passer à l'échelon
supranationale mais elle a quand même
réussi à réduire un peu les
souverainetés nationales donc on n'a
plus vraiment des états souverains qui
contrôle pleinement leurs frontières
mais on n'a pas non plus une supra
nationalité européenne une nation
européenne qui est capable de vraiment
contrôler ses frontières extérieures et
en plus si un grand égoïsme les pays du
nord délègue à l'italie l'espagne et la
grèce en gros la gestion des premiers
arrivants et c'est eux qui doivent payer
ce qu'on se lave les mains et mais le
problème c'est qu'une fois qu'ils ont
pénétré un pays européen ensuite ils
peuvent circuler grâce à schengen dans
tous les autres pays européens et c'est
ça qui a motivé le départ des anglais ça
on n'est pas là pour le justifier mais
les anglais ce serait peut-être rester
dans l'union européenne s'ils avaient
pensé que l'union européenne ne les
empêchait pas de décider qui vient ou
pas chez eux quelque part on peut pas
les blâmer totalement de vouloir décider
qui vient ou pas sur leur territoire au
chlore absence or comment l'europe elle
est dans un entre deux ll est dans une
sorte d'app senteurs de de souveraineté
c'est un espace de des souverainistes à
sion qui je le répète a détruit les
souverainetés nationales en partie mais
sans créer une souveraineté
supranationale et c'est pour ça que
kissinger déjà au début du processus
européen on en parle dans le livre là il
disait europe quel numéro de téléphone
qui décident l'allemagne la france le
président tournant enfin le pays qui
préside pendant six mois l'union
européenne le vrai président l'union
européenne le président de la commission
une véritable cacophonie et c'est triste
à dire parce que j'aime l'europe et le
projet européen mais à l'extérieur les
turcs les russes les chinois les
américains ils rigolent quand ils voient
la cacophonie européenne car c'est un
véritable chaos organisationnel et
regarder comment erdogan a humilié les
européens en recevant à un tandem est en
fait en ne faisant asseoir que le
monsieur est on se rappelle ursula von
der leyen qui a été humiliée et et
monsieur michel n'est même pas défendu
qui ne m'aiment pas montrer son
indignation l'europe parce qu'elles
n'arrivent même pas à parler d'une voix
alary femmes même pas envoyé à un sommet
représentant à la rive avec deux ou
trois représentants donc l'europe
aujourd'hui c'est un espace désorganisée
et un ovni un objet politique non
identifié
merci beaucoup alexandre del valle je
rappelle donc que vous êtes co auteur de
ce livre combien de voir la
mondialisation dangereuse vers le
déclassement de l'occident aux éditions
l'artilleur merci beaucoup étaient avec
nous ce soir est resté avec nous dans
quelques instants nous parlerons du
mouvement de contestation qui secoue la
guadeloupe et la martinique les deux ils
sont paralysés depuis dix jours par une
crise sociale et économique notamment
avec la baisse du pouvoir d'achat alors
la pauvreté s'est elle a gravé en france
métropolitaine et en outre-mer depuis qu
vide on en parle aussi avec jacques
sapir et son édito
[Musique]
comment abordez vous cette épreuve vous
êtes vous rendu au procès je suis allé
aux premières auditions du procès j'ai
trouvé vraiment que le monde finalement
était formé de gens merveilleux aidé de
jean ignoble en fait vous ne savez pas
comment votre fils est mort vous devez
enquêter sur tout et vous confronter ils
étaient ni sur la liste des morts nés
sur l'île d'eubée sinistralité
hopitalisés il était nulle part est ce
qu'on peut vivre malgré cette douleur
quand j'ai écrit à la fois je souffrais
parce que ça me rappelait des beaux
souvenirs avec stéphane et en même temps
c'était très douloureux et puis
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçu que ça
permettait d'extraire de de moi même
toute cette histoire est donc ça m'a
apporté un peu de recul un peu
d'apaisement mais la douleur est la
couleur seront là jusqu'à ma mort
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose
une convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
où
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash nous vous parlerons de
tout sans langue de bois
[Musique]
on a tous pensé qu'on descendait du
singe vous avez brisé ce tabou dans une
certaine mesure dans deux singes le
malheur c'est que quand on dit descente
des sages on a l'impression qu'on
descend des chimpanzés et pas du tout
les chimpanzés et nous sommes cousins à
grand mère maternelle qui était bretonne
me disais si toi tu es descendu sa joie
sur rampe a révélé nous un secret vous
en avez mangé du mam où je me trouve à
fouiller en sibérie et puis un beau
matin dans le trou que j'avais commencé
à creuser je trouve de lait tout comme
ce quelque chose de bien les grands en
filaments je suis étonnée je râle je
dirais que ce sont des collègues russes
qui sont venus tripatouiller le fond de
ma recherche et puis à force de tirer
dessus comme rien ne venait je me suis
aperçu que j'étais sur le dos de
mammouth
[Musique]
récemment le gouvernement français a
violemment réagi à l'annoncé d'un
mémorandum d'intention passé entre
wagner et le gouvernement malien la
france a été progressivement perçue est
considérée comme une armée d'occupation
qui protégeait les régimes en place au
mali mais aussi au tchad la france ne se
retire pas ni du mali du sahel s'agit
bien d'une transformation une
réorganisation ce ne sont plus les
militaires français forcément qu'ils
sont aux premières lignes ce sont les
militaires maliens au regard de la
situation actuelle il est clair que nous
avons fait l'essai qu'il est va falloir
en tirer les leçons et cesser de mettre
sur le compte de fée news ou campagne d'
influence le ressenti est l'état
d'esprit des populations
si on ne veut pas se retrouver comme les
américains en afghanistan
[Musique]
le maintien de l'ordre une doctrine qui
est à la fois saluée dans le monde on
entend souvent parler d'excellence
française allait aussi critiqué ces
dernières années quand on observe le
maintien de l'ordre en france au cours
du 20e siècle et début du 21e il ya
extrêmement peu de victimes même si un
mort au maintien de l'ordre et une
catastrophe est tout à fait les bras on
a vu des personnes gravement blessées on
a entendu aussi le terme violences
policières ce débat sur les violences
policières ce qu'il a toujours existé où
il a toujours existé ou la première
grande manifestation parisienne du 6
février 34 on a même pu craindre la
disparition de la toute jeune garde
républicaine mobile dans la presse
s'était déchaînée sur ce qui était
réellement le noyau dur du dispositif de
maintien d'ordre à l'époque
[Musique]
il est 21h merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième partie d'émission au
sommaire le mouvement de contestation
qui secoue la guadeloupe et la
martinique véhicules calcinés incendies
pillages et barrages routiers les deux
ils sont paralysés depuis dix jours par
une crise sociale et économique une
crise qui a fait surface après une
opposition à l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants un notamment est parmi les
raisons de la colère aux antilles
l'inégalité sociale renforcée par la
crise sanitaire ou encore la baisse du
pouvoir d'achat alors la pauvreté s'est
aggravée en france métropolitaine tout
comme en outre-mer depuis le coc vide
sur la question deux thèses s'affrontent
nous le verrons dans l'élite aux échos
de jacques sapir
[Musique]
la colère ne retombe pas aux antilles
outre l'obligation vaccinale de
nombreuses raisons alimente ce
ras-le-bol en guadeloupe et en
martinique
l'inégalité sociale renforcée par la
crise sanitaire le chômage des jeunes
les conditions de vie ou encore la
baisse du pouvoir d'achat la martinie
sur les traces de la guadeloupe et le
mouvement pourrait s'élargir à la
polynésie française une situation qui
inquiète le secteur du tourisme alors
qu'elle proche la haute saison marion
godall
barricades au milieu de la route pas une
voiture à l'horizon les manifestants
sont toujours déterminés à se faire
entendre
obligation vaccinale instauration du
pass and it erp ou encore hausse des
prix du carburant autant de raisons pour
la population de dresser ces barrages
depuis le début
nous n'avons pas vu nos élus avec nous
nous n'avons pas entendu et jusqu'à
présent séparés tant que nous n'aurons
pas des élus en responsabilité nous
aurons toujours cette difficulté là vous
pouvez parler tant que vous voulez à la
rectrice vous pouvez parler tant que
vous voulez auprès fait vous pouvez
parler tant que vous voulez au directeur
de l'hôpital même si celui ci est un
guadeloupéen il n'est là que pour
exécuter
c'est toute une économie locale qui
tourne au ralenti sur le bord des routes
les bars et les restaurants sont fermés
l'approvisionnement devient difficile et
les employés sont parfois dans
l'impossibilité de rejoindre leur lieu
de travail un mouvement de contestation
qui inquiète les professionnels du
tourisme est ce qu'il ya des annulations
il ya quelques années la soeur audi
prévu que des quatre groupes par par
semaine et la hâte le groupe ii qui
devait arriver aujourd'hui fait c'est la
bnp ils sont en partie cela il avant de
vous puis soir venu ils viennent par
leur peut s'habiller fait tout a été
annulé pour le moment tous les autres
groupes sont en standby ou soir eu les
situations difficiles pour un secteur
déjà grandement impacté par la crise
sanitaire ici à la plage de la datcha au
gosier les touristes sont désabusés mais
je comprends complètement le fait que
ces personnes
des choses avait il indiqué mais c'est
vrai que pour nous c'est dommage parce
que ça ne gâche un peu les vacances
après moi je connais un peu la
guadeloupe et je suis venu pour voir la
famille donc c'est non c'est un autre
objectif à bas les vacances c'est un
petit peu un petit peu compliqué on va
dire puisque avec les barrages dont on
peut pas passer on est un petit peu
racketter aussi quand même on me demande
de l'argent pour pouvoir passer ça s'est
passé pâques où je pense que c'est pas
vraiment pour moi c'est pas de la grève
donc on a trouvé en fait des chemins
intermédiaires en passant par
l'intérieur des terres par exemple pour
venir ici voilà il a fallu qu'on fasse
un petit détour pour le mois de décembre
le taux de réservation dans les hôtels
dépasse les 70% le comité du tourisme de
l'archipel reste donc positif à
condition que le taux d'annulation reste
raisonnable
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
philippe bélair secrétaire général cgt
santé guadeloupe bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous ce conflit social qui a donc
déclenché par une opposition à la
vaccination obligatoire un des soignants
et au passage iter on l'a dit le cache
évidemment également une défiance à
l'égard de la politique menée par le
gouvernement comment l'expliquer
on expliquer quoi exactement
est-ce que c'est l'entêtement du
gouvernement où notre détermination
lorsqu'il s'agit véritablement
depuis le mois de juillet le 17 juillet
exactement nous sommes en train de
marcher d'expliquer à la population de
faire en sorte que non seulement la
population vient aussi aux responsables
politiques puissent entendre horizons au
non sens des mesures sanitaires qui sont
prises et aucun retour le faire nous
écrivons nous faisons des propositions
expliquant la situation nous expliquons
que cette loi ne peut pas être
applicable six mille îles déjà
handicapé pendant un certain nombre de
réformes hospitalières et une
restructuration de l'offre sanitaire qui
qui nous a pénalisés énormément jusqu'à
ce jour
le gouvernement est dans une logique
implacable le droit dans ses bottes il
veut appliquer vaille que vaille sa loi
de 5 août dernier la situation le
problème c'est qu'en face il ya une
population ce n'est pas seulement ça a
commencé avec les soignants mettre notre
top la population mobilisée et très
peut-être qu'à mobiliser même si des
tentatives de renversement du sont
tentées mais ça ne marche pas ça ne
mange pas population est ainsi en moins
à nos côtés
quand vous dites c'est toi ne peut pas
s'appliquer en guadeloupe sur l'île
c'est vrai que le gouvernement veut
simplement peut être appliqué la loi
française la guadeloupe fait partie
intégrante de de la france est une forme
de principe d'égalité qu'est ce que vous
pouvez pour y répondre à cet argument
je tombe bien mal sommes le seul
problème c'est que lorsqu'il a fallu
imposer le club icaunais wattrelos on
enfile dérogation donc je m'étonne qu'on
me sorte c'est un argument aujourd'hui
s'il ya eu des rogations que nous
empoisonner je vois pas pourquoi il y
avoir une dérogation parce que ce soit
comme une demande dont ce n'est pas
l'absence de vaccination contrairement à
ce que d'autres qu'on est en tête de
vouloir dire à notre place non nous
sommes pas anti anti vaccin puisque nous
sommes des soignants c'est ce qu'alain
comble d'être anti maxi l'histoire
seulement nous estimons avec tous les
scandales sanitaires je lui dis et redis
je le répète tous les sens scandale à sa
vidéo qui ont eu lieu à 10h20 nous on
dit aujourd'hui que maintenant il y en a
marre aujourd'hui s'il n'apparaît plus
apparu de nous dire ce qui est bon pour
nous au regard de ce que nous voyons au
point de nous voisins à côté il y à des
traitements qui marche il y a les
vaccins conventionnel qui existe et
je ne vois pas pourquoi on veut lui
imposer d'ailleurs je me dis que la loi
parle d' obligation vaccinale de la loi
ne parle pas de l'obligation dé
s'incliner d'accord or le s'il ya une
éducation pas et va parallèlement le
gouvernement japonais
les essais cliniques des produits en à m
donc il y a quand même dans dans le
comportement
dans les options prises par le
gouvernement même d'une enfance pour
vous c'est une question peut-être
au-delà des mots tout simplement de
confiance brisé et ce depuis plusieurs
années depuis le scandale des pesticides
dans les années 70 80
il y a
la confiance est de mise ici vrai mais
ce n'est pas seulement une affaire de
moules de sémantique c'est très
important on se peut il ya beaucoup de
confusion qui sont faites pour pouvoir
dénaturer notre mouvement nous sommes
seulement une fois anti-vaccins je le
répète je tiens à le souligner dans ce
cas si petit que ça doit être clair
c'est un mouvement où on revendique au
regard de ce qui s'est passé dans le
passé revendique d'avoir le droit de
choix de ce qu'on peut nous donner par
ailleurs il faut que je vous explique
que nous on ne panique pas interne par
rapport à la pandémie pas pour vivre ce
pourquoi parce que nous avons l'habitude
nous avons l'habitude des pandémies nous
avons l'habitude et j'ai vu ce gâchis
qu'il ya ding grippe etc nous avons
cette habitude
s'est pas vraiment comme les gages on ne
peut pas
effaroucher avec ça on peut pas nous
faire peur avec ça la mesure où nous
avons jugé en vidéo parce qu'une
tradition épidémique donc si notre
revendication est légitime c'est bien
parce qu'en fait nous sommes bien placés
pour aaa à une et une épidémie ou
pandémie
ça c'est bon ça c'est pas bon le
ministre d outre mer un sébastien
lecornu 1 a confirmé qu'il se rendrait
prochainement en guadeloupe et en
martinique à une fois que l'ordre sera
rétabli il arrive un peu tard vous
auriez peut-être aimé le voir avant
il arrive non seulement un peu tard mais
voit pas ce qu'on pouvait faire très
sincèrement
la chaîne chose qui est pour tous nous
parce qu'il faut bien être clair nous
sommes déterminés
ce qui la seule et unique chose qui doit
être clair c'est que
qu'il vienne lui ou qu'il envoie une
mission qu'elle compte nous demandons
une négociation que cette négociation
repose sur nos revendications qui sont
très très clairs
voilà donc qu'ils viennent je ne sais
pas je sais pas ce qu'est ce que ça va
donner toujours est il que
aujourd'hui je crois c'est lui même que
c'est lui même c'est notre ministre qui
a
opposé
d'élargir la vaccination etc le nouveau
plan par rapport à horgues et de débit
dans l'hexagone
si si l'opposition était un peu écoutés
je pense que
l'organisation sanitaire par rapport à
mon niveau a été tout autre et je pense
qu'un mystérieux pas à ce niveau là peau
je le répète je les dis souvent aux
antennes dernièrement pour nous c'est
une gestion idéologique ce n'est pas une
gestion syndic merci beaucoup d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
monsieur baylet remercie à vous
et moment sociale aux antilles donc pour
dénoncer entre autres la baisse aussi du
pouvoir d'achat on entend souvent parler
peut-on dire que la pauvreté s'est
aggravée en france métropolitaine et
dans les territoires d'outre-mer de
piles qu'ovide sur la question deux
thèses s'affrontent si on en croit
l'insee la politique du quoiqu'il en
tout coûte est liée à la pandémie elle a
permis de stabiliser cette pauvreté mais
le secours catholique lui tire la
sonnette d'alarmé dans son dernier
rapport place tout de suite l élite aux
échos de jacques sapir
[Musique]
bonsoir jacques maire soit d'être avec
nous on en parle souvent ces fameuses
deux thèses qui s'affrontent donc y
croire une bonne fois pour toutes sur
cette question de la pauvreté en france
l'insee ou de secours catholique mais je
pense que les deux ont raison mais parce
qu'il ne parle pas de la même chose
alors oui effectivement quand le
gouvernement dit le quoi qu'il en coûte
à protéger une grande partie des
français où il a incontestablement
réseau oui et on peut le voir d'ailleurs
en particulier sur toute une série de
deux salariés mais quand le secours
catholique dit ceux qui n'ont pas été
protégé par justement cette espèce de
parapluies du quoi qu'il en coûte ont vu
leur situation se dégrader durant
l'année du coc vide et se dégrader
encore actuellement il a aussi
incontestablement raison alors on
commence avec les chiffres de l'insee
pour aller bien dans le détail que
distille alors ils disent que les jours
qui se situe à 60 % du seuil de pauvreté
il faut d'abord expliquer que ce qu'on
appelle 60 % du seuil de pauvreté c'est
un revenu net qui soit égal à 60% du
revenu médian pas de revenus moyens
autrement dit ces 11 100 euros par mois
et bien ce chiffre est aujourd'hui à peu
près stable il avait monté en 2018 un
petit peu redescendue maison il est
resté stable en
2018 et 2019 bon donc ça c'est une c'est
une première chose après évidemment se
pose la question de savoir est ce que ce
chiffre est réellement pertinent mais ça
c'est un autre problème et c'est pauvre
jacques qui sont ils alors les pauvres
qui sont concernés justement parle le
rapport qu'a fait le secours catholique
il faut voir que c'est plusieurs choses
1 d'abord il faut dire leur nombre le
secours catholique estime qu'il reçoit
aujourd'hui 7 millions je dis bien 7
millions de demandes de soi disant de
l'aide alimentaire si on reprend le
chiffre de l'insee il ya quand même
quelque chose qui est intéressant il
faut voir que et on le voit sur le
graphique il faut voir que suivant les
catégories c'est très différent alors 40
% des chômeurs à peu près sont dans
cette catégorie mais il ya aussi
7 % des patrons de pme et ça c'est des
indépendants mais ça c'est important
parce que quand j'ai dit que la moyenne
nationale c'était à 14,6 pour cent on
voit que c'est plus importe donc ça
prouve qu'il y à aussi ce qu'on appelle
les actifs pauvres si vous voulez les
gens qui sont actifs qui ont un emploi
mais qui sont pauvres alors dernier
point qui est très important c'est
effectivement la part des enfants on se
rend compte que 1 enfant sur cinq en
france 20% des enfants sont dans des
familles qui sont considérés comme
pauvres et que dit le secours catholique
maintenant alors justement le secours
catholique insiste beaucoup sur le fait
qu' aujourd'hui alors ils l'aident à peu
près 7 à 8 millions de personnes il
insiste sur le fait que le revenu médian
des gens qu il n a baissé et se situe
aujourd'hui à un niveau très faible 540
euros contre 740 euros ce qui serait à
peu près la moyenne pour les gens qui
sont considérés comme très pauvre donc
ça c'est un premier point le deuxième
point est bien c'est que le nombre de
gens qui ont recours à l'aide
alimentaire a énormément augmenté et il
a continué d'augmenter l'année de l'aco
vite c'est pratiquement 7 millions de
personnes
troisième chose qui est aussi
extrêmement inquiétante c'est le fait
que un peu plus du quart de ces
personnes 1 27% et bien sont dans ce
qu'on appelle une grande insécurité
alimentaire lors qu'est ce que ça veut
dire vous avez dire que
plusieurs fois par mois ils passent une
journée sans manger autrement dit on est
là en face de gens qui ont ceint c'est
pas simplement qu'ils peuvent mal se
nourrir qu'ils ont besoin d aide que ce
soit les restos du coeur ou le secours
catholique pour améliorer le repas non
ils ont faim et 27% c'est quand même un
chiffre très important et le dernier
point sur lequel insiste le secours
catholique c'est le fait que dans les
gens qui viennent avoir accès si vous
voulez à son aide alimentaire il y a des
gens qui ont un salaire
et qui sont au dessus du seuil de
pauvreté pas beaucoup mais qui sont un
petit peu au dessus du seuil de pauvreté
sauf que ce sont des gens qui ont de
très grosses dépenses contraintes alors
que ce soit le loyer ça peut être aussi
l'endettement 1 qui joue lui et donc ils
n'ont plus assez d'argent pour se
nourrir donc il y à bien un problème
assez majeur de pauvreté même de grande
pauvreté en france on a beaucoup parlé
des étudiants justement dans cette crise
que dit le secours catholique alors le
secours catholique est aussi très
impressionné par le fait que les
demandes aide alimentaire ont été très
forte chez les jeunes dont les étudiants
évidemment plus 6% dans l'année 2020 et
on comprend tout à fait pourquoi parce
que c'était des jeunes qui faisait très
souvent ce qu'on appelle un petit boulot
alors ce petit boulot ce thème pourrait
peut-être coursier vous ai travaillé
dans des restaurants dans des bars etc
tout ça ça à faire dit si vous voulez
tout le secteur de l'événementiel qui
était un grand pourvoyeur justement de
ces petits boulots et bien ça à fermer
et même s'ils ont une petite bourse bien
ils se sont retrouvés avec quasiment
rien et or je dirais du filet de
sécurité déployés par l'état est ce à
dire alors que le quoi qu'il en coûte
n'a pas marché dans ce cas là si vous
voulez c'est toujours la même chose oui
de quoi qu'il en coûte à marcher pour
les gens qui ont été protégés sauf qu'il
faut quand même à rajouter là une chose
le quoi qu'il en coûte le le système en
fait de chômage partiel qui a été mis en
place dans le cadre de quoi qu'il en
coûte
indemniser 84 % du montant du salaire
alors bon très bien quand vous avez un
salaire supérieur à 2000 euros nets dans
84% ça représente une perte mais c'est
pas grave quand vous êtes au smic et
quand justement vous allez finir le mois
ric rac voire légèrement à découvert est
bien perdre 16 % par rapport à un smic
ça peut être tout à fait dramatique
ajoutons une chose à cela le fait que
même si vous n'êtes pas touchés par ce
genre de problème vous pouvez avoir des
charges qui viennent s'ajouter à cela et
le fait que les cantines scolaires n'ont
pas fonctionné pendant une partie
c'était l'une des raisons pour
lesquelles le gouvernement a tenu
au soul et à la rentrée 2020 que les
écoles restent ouverts le plus longtemps
possible parce que qu'est ce qui s'était
passé lors du premier confinant les
cantines scolaires ont été fermés et
donc
cette nourriture des enfants qui étaient
payés par là que par la collectivité ce
soit par l'état par les collectivités
régionales et c est bien elle est
revenue à la charge de famille qui
voyaient déjà leurs revenus se réduire
donc on comprend d'une certaine manière
quels sont les mécanismes de
l'appauvrissement des gens avec l'aco
vide est ce que on peut dire sur cette
question finalement que la pauvreté est
de retour malheureusement oui
malheureusement oui et on voit bien
prenons par exemple ce qui se passe vous
venez juste d'en parler ce qui se passe
dans les antilles à la guadeloupe en
martinique ce sont des régions où nous
avons plus de 30% de la population qui
est sous le seuil de la pauvreté donc on
voit bien qu'il ya des régions où c'est
extrêmement grave et puis globalement
oui c'est un problème qui aujourd'hui se
pose on voit si on recense toutes les
données qui sont fournis par les
différentes ong que ce soit le secours
populaire que ce soit le secours
catholique que ce soit aussi d'ailleurs
les restaurants du coeur qui fournissent
les données de ce point de vue là eh
bien on voit qu'il y à une montée de
l'appauvrissement alors il ya une partie
de la population qui s'est assez bien
sorti de la crise de l'aco vide vous
savez la france fait les français
globalement ils ont fait 165 milliards
d' épargne
pendant cette année sauf que 30% de la
population on désépargner et c'est cette
population là qui a réellement souffert
de la crise de la queue vite c'est cette
population là que l'on retrouve dans
toutes les enquêtes qu'elle soit faite
par le secours populaire par le secours
catholique ou par les restos du coeur et
je pense que c'est une question qui va à
un moment ou à un autre
pénétrez dans la campagne présidentielle
et il faudra que tous les candidats y
compris le président candidat se
prononce à son sujet merci beaucoup et
on verra si ce sera le cas merci
beaucoup j'accepte fier d'avoir été avec
nous et je vous dis à la semaine
prochaine merci
est toujours en france une bataille une
bataille menée depuis des années par
roger laurent sa vie a basculé en juin
1992 il entreprenait alors des travaux
pour chez lui pour faciliter l'accès à
sa fille polyhandicapée mais après un
accident et est en piteux et amputé des
deux jambes un handicap qui selon lui
n'a jamais été acceptée par son
employeur reportage à haubourdin dans le
nord avec renault parquet et sandra ji
young oh
voilà plus d'un quart de siècle que
roger laurent vit l'enfer ce salarié de
l'entreprise kharg il n'a jamais cessé
de batailler avec son employeur pour
faire reconnaître ses droits en 1992
c'est à titre privé qu'il entreprend des
travaux à son domicile un accident de
chantier transforme son existence
des potins depuis complète en laisse pas
de famille ou
sur bois dans une allée d'un mètre de
large sur
en cinq minutes c'est du vote
du chopper ils étaient pressés ou à tout
prix des 5 ou 10 parce que le béton
ses bottes se remplissent de béton à
s'édifier qui entraîne une brûlure au
troisième degré on doit l'enquêté d'une
jambe une maladie nosocomiale entraîne
des complications
il perd sa seconde jambe ils bénéficient
alors du statut de travailleur handicapé
son employeur aménage son poste mais
l'aggravation de son état de santé et
les nouvelles opérations change la donne
les responsables de kharg il se montre
selon lui agacé est impatient d'en finir
tous les angles
avec la direction les retraites dorées
j'écoute troc à
prendre en compte
papa c'est quoi je suis c'est quoi des
histoires
c'est sérieux une chaussée si l'on sait
pas s'ils peuvent apprendre du passé
handicapés et bakounine aussi
en arrêt maladie depuis 1997 roger
laurent touchent une pension
d'invalidité de 1900 euros et reçoit une
fiche de paie avec un net à payer 2 0
euros bien qu'absents de l'entreprise
durant 24 ans kharg il n'a jamais pris
l'initiative de régler sa situation
mais dernièrement il a enfin été
convoqué à un entretien préalable à un
licenciement pour inaptitude
il est soutenu par la cgt et entend
faire valoir ses droits pour avoir une
discussion entre le long roger la
direction et le ps on se rend compte que
ces indemnités sont divisé par deux sur
ce qui avait été annoncé ce qui paraît
illogique fiche comprend que sa colère
aussi parce que c'est pas logique est ce
que c'est un malentendu est ce que c'est
pas mal entendu je sais pas
aujourd'hui âgé de 60 ans roger laurent
a décidé d'attaquer car guilo
prud'hommes pour obtenir réparation
contactée par téléphone la société n'a
pas répondu à notre appel
mais avant de refermer cette émission ce
jeudi a été marquée par la journée
internationale pour l'élimination de la
violence à l'égard des femmes un
rassemblement dans le siège mon ami tout
politique les militants dénoncent les
affaires récentes qui secoue le monde
politique il estime par ailleurs que la
stratégie du gouvernement pour lutter
contre ces agissements n'est pas à la
hauteur des besoins et réclament la
démission de gérald darmanin
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui d'avoir ce
rempart contre
les violences faites aux femmes est
particulièrement
c'est un rassemblement
collection karabatic
finalement sur les réseaux sociaux
ensuite à une tribu médian
j'ai des mousses névian
perpétue au sein de notre activité
[Applaudissements]
10g d'acceptation de lancer la démission
les élus concernés donc notamment
dharmanand christophe girard et max
roach a exigé la mise en place de
cellules des cours d'eau semblent toutes
nos parties et nos institutions la levée
de l'immunité parlementaire avant qu'il
n'y ait plus
d'instruction dans le cadre d' enquête
pour violences sexuelles on était plus
près du ministère de l'intérieur
l'éclat mais un des points saillants des
dysfonctionnements du show politique sur
les questions de violence y est c'est
sexuel qui est la présence de darmanin à
l'intérieur mais ça vient s'ajouter
vient s'ajouter à cela l'actualité le
déni claude à l'eau puisque là dans
quelques heures une heure et demie va
être diffusée sur diffusé ce soir sur
envoyé spécial à
[Musique]
enquête dans laquelle témoignent
plusieurs femmes des agressions
d'agression sexuelle dont elle dénonce
nicolas hulot est pour ça qu est ce que
ça veut dire en fait donc il ya des
femmes qui témoignent d'agression
sexuelle de nicolas hulot il ya des
femmes actuellement une pub herrmann
alors alex türk et des faveurs sexuelles
à partir de sa position ça veut dire
qu'on a des milices je t'aime
gouvernement mâcon
qui sont dans cette position d'art ça
veut dire quoi sur le président de la
république ça veut dire quoi pour une
boutique le ministre à propos de la
grande cause du quinquennat et que lui
en fait qu'est-ce qui fait elle protège
les sommes pas protégés des agresseurs
et c'est la fin de cette émission merci
de l'avoir suivi rendez vous lundi dès
20h10 sida n'oubliez pas de réagir de
commenter ou posez vos questions sur le
télégramme daté france en attendant
l'actualité continue toute la soirée
[Musique]
suite